bevor die ausbildung zum karl soldaten
oder circa soldatin beginnen kann wird
eine körperliche leistungsfähigkeit
überprüft los geht es mit dem
liegestütze voraussetzungen dafür sind
die ruf kraft die schubkraft und die
armmuskulatur auch im kampfsport sind
liegestütz ein wichtiger teil des
trainings aber die gestützt ist nicht
gleich wieder stützen es gibt viele
varianten bei der eignungsprüfung kiste
mit dem hinten schulterbreit auseinander
wenn du in die ausrüstung ist dann liegt
die schuld öffentlich über den daumen
auch die vorstellung die bitte beachten
deine füße dürfen maximal hüftbreit
auseinander fallen was auf die
körperspannung auf schaut das schon zu
rücken und gesäß auf einer limousine
also nicht durchringen und auch keinen
kapsel doppel machten bei der gerade
hunde in position oberarm schulter und
rücken sollten da auf einer linie seien
nur dann gelten die geschätzte werte und
dann gehst du wieder gerade hoch in die
anfangsposition wenn du am anfang noch
nicht in irgendwelche stück schafft
kannst du beim training für die
eignungsprüfung auch mit erleichterten
liegestützen beginnen um die muskulatur
für die liegestütze zu fördern kann man
auch übungen der grabkammer machen zum
beispiel bank dürften aber am besten
trainiert manley gestützt durch
liegestütze und so schafft man nicht nur
die eignungsprüfung sondern man wird
auch die bisher